sie sprechen die infrastruktur an in
berlin wo wir beide jetzt stehen gibt es
die debatte darüber den flughafen tegel
möglicherweise zu schließen diese
stimmen kamen aus dem berliner senat wie
sehen sie das als verkehrsminister klare
botschaft wir haben gerade
verkehrsministerkonferenz gehabt der mit
den länderverkehrsminister klare
botschaft stabile grundversorgung
erhalten für die stabile grundversorgung
zählt die flughäfen denken sie an die
vielen frachtflieger denken sie an die
die als urlaubsrückkehrer wieder nach
deutschland zurückkommen das heißt eine
stadt wie berlin die vor 70 jahren rund
eine luftbrücke hatte und dort auch
gerettet wurde eine stadt der luftbrücke
darf nicht so geschichtsvergessen sein
dass man jetzt einfach weil natürlich
fast auf null runtergefahren ist der
betrieb einfach mal flughafen
geschlossen wird die hauptstadt braucht
die anbindung über den flughafen die
beiden flughäfen und da wir gerade dabei
sind einen großen flughafen endlich
fertig zu bekommen ist jetzt die
situation beide flughäfen die jetzt zur
verfügung stehen offen zu halten
vielleicht auch für notsituationen für
flüge die man unbedingt braucht
leichtfertig einen flughafen zu
schließen wäre jetzt ein fataler fehler
und ich werde alles dafür tun was das
bundes interesse an den flughafen ist
die in berlin ja einem bundesanteil
haben dass wir uns dagegen sperren
ich habe auch partner in der
bundesregierung wir haben nicht nur
einen flughafen der mit personen
angeflogen wird sondern auch mit fracht
aber wir haben auch einen
regierungsflughafen das heißt
deutschland muss flexibel bleiben in
allen infrastruktureinrichtungen
wir lassen die bahn fahren wir lassen
natürlich autoverkehr und lkw-verkehr zu
wir müssen die baustellen weiterhin
bespielen und wir brauchen natürlich
auch flughäfen flughafeninfrastruktur
muss erhalten bleiben für die stabile
grundversorgung berlin würde da eine
fehlentscheidung treffen sie haben die
luftbrücke vor 70 jahren angesprochen
und werfen dem berliner senat
geschichtsvergessenheit vor wie gut
funktioniert denn diese neue luftbrücke
in
corona zeit momentan also was die fracht
betrifft ist gerade die anbindung über
die lufthansa was an material reinkommt
was wir auch herausfliegen man muss ja
daran denken dass auch
wirtschaftsbereiche in der industrie
weiterhin produzieren und in den märkten
der welt doch noch deutsche produkte
jetzt in der schwierigen phase heraus
geliefert werden müssen dass diese
fracht kapazitäten hochgefahren werden
wir müssen ja diese zeitliche stelle
ausgleichen
china war jetzt drei wochen vorher dran
deswegen sind keine schiffe losgefahren
in china für die deutschen häfen jetzt
müssen wir das über die fracht
ausgleichen
über die luftfracht das heißt das ist
eine flexible möglichkeit und deswegen
zweiter punkt heiko maas der
außenminister organisiert die rückkehr
der urlauber nach deutschland
ich bekomme auch jeden tag 10 15 mails
von deutschen die noch einen kontakt zur
deutschen botschaft brauchen und wie
organisierende sehr sehr konzentriert
auch über die reiseunternehmen dass die
deutschen zurückkehren in ihre heimat
und dass wir da wirklich eine luftbrücke
sowohl für die fracht als auch für die
urlaubsrückkehrer aufbauen und aufgebaut
haben sehr konzentriert wir haben 250
bis 300 tausend urlauber vor zwei wochen
in den urlaubsdestinationen gehabt und
jetzt haben wir so die hälfte zurück
geholt also da ist noch eine menge
arbeit